this has been a week that's been
dominated by the economy as a
businessman when you hear warnings from
the Bank of England talking about the
possibility of a recession if Britain
votes to leave the EU and you hear the
IMF saying that an exit would range from
being pretty bad very very bad does that
not give you pause for thought in your
commitment to leaving the EU well either
you've got to take these people
reasonably seriously but I think you've
also got to look at their track record
which is not very good and we were all
told 10 or 15 years ago that if we
didn't join the euro that the economy
would tank and the city would run into
enormous difficulties didn't happen when
we were in the exchange rate mechanism
we were told not least by John Major
that if we left we'd have high levels of
inflation and again the economy going
down exactly the reverse occurred and
none of these people were for saw the
crash in 2008 I mean are we ready to
take it all that seriously I think sort
of groups think about all this nobody
wants to be out of sync with other
people but i'm not sure these risks are
grossly exaggerated what kind of
government the Bank of England says
these can leave campaigners are in
denial about the economic impact and
it's it's not just the Bank of England
is earnest the IMF the OECD's a
president obama its institutions lining
up you say they are all wrong well all I
am saying is I think they were all wrong
over the euro and they were all wrong
over the exchange rate mechanism they
were all wrong over the crash in 2008 so
are we really to believe they're going
to be right this time what about Boris
Johnson then Boris Johnson in the pet
newspapers today has compared European
efforts to to build a super state as he
would define it to Hitler's attempts to
dominate the continent what do you make
of those remarks well I'd Boris Johnson
is Boris Johnson I'm and I think it is a
bit over the top to be honest with you
I'm is obviously some element of
underlying truth about all this but I
think that this is a rather welfare
league considerably exaggerated we're
putting the case and of course he's one
of the most prominent spokespeople for
vote leave a group that you've left it
was it because of this kind of thing
that you left know what Anubis but
cause vote Libya's across party
organization but it hadn't got it but
the tickly distinctive labour voice and
it does happen under Stuart there and
Frank field and Graham stringer so it's
got some important labour figures on its
board but I thought that what was needed
was a distinctive labour campaign for
breck said and that's brought I'm very
much involved it but the Electoral
Commission chose vote leave as the main
party at the main group to represent
that view doesn't it confuse matters if
you if you peel off I don't think it
does particularly but I think on the
whole labor people like dealing with
labor organizations and we've certainly
had a very very strong response to the
reestablishment that they believe over
the last couple of weeks so I think I'm
pleased with the decision has been taken
and yet there have been suggestions
there have been tensions behind the
scenes within vote leave and then we had
this email but appeared to threaten at
both the government and ITV about plans
to put Cameron up against Nigel Farage
in debate ahead of the EU referendum do
you think the vote leave risks losing
some credibility among voters well it's
very lively people at vote leave who
obviously have their point of view and I
think any organization like this which
is cross party is bound to have some
tensions but I think labour beavers done
a very good job of bracing funding for
the campaign it's fighting it's got some
very talented people there it's got a
very talented board I think it's doing a
pretty good job on the whole but what
are your reservations and how do they
treat labour people well I think there's
been some problems about treated labour
people in a different way from
conservative people and I understand
this but this is really why I think it's
been helpful to split off the Labour
specifically labour campaign the way
that has been done and I'm pleased with
the way things are going beginning a
very good response I think there is a
very substantial block of left-leaning
labour leaning votes which is brexit
orientated which needs nurturing and
that's what I'm doing are you
disappointed that the cat that Jeremy
Corbyn is not in your camp many people
had thought that he might be you're a
skeptic when you disappointed that he
plunked for the in campaign well I was a
bit disappointed yes because jeremy
corbyn has got a long track record of
being a very Euroskeptic but i
understand where years and it needs
part of a party which is very you're a
file in the House of Commons I'm sure he
doesn't field it can take on too many
different battles of bunce and I think
that he's there for gone along with the
sentiments of his colleagues yes it is a
bit disappointing but understandable as
one of Labor's biggest donors how
satisfied are you about how Jeremy
Corbyn is leading the party at the
moment given the local and Scottish
elections last week labour coming third
behind the Tories in Scotland for
example do you feel he's doing one
enough well I don't think the results
last week when nearly as bad as a lot of
pundits said they would be for the
Labour Party I think this is left they
were good wouldn't I don't you know
particularly good but they weren't
nearly as disastrous as a lot of people
said it might be of labour lost 50 or 60
seats a lot of people were saying they
were going to lose more than 200 so I
think you've got to get the results in
perspective but i think that jeremy
corbyn has been a wake-up call for the
Labour Party I think the party needs to
have a lot of rethinking on the economy
and other issues and I very much hope
this will happen I'd like to take part
in that process over the next few years
what about Sadiq Khan the new mayor of
london's advice to jeremy corbyn he
talked about wanting needing to do more
to address the concerns of ordinary
people have a broader church do you
think he's on the right lines yes I
think any party that's going to see his
power has simply got to have a large
enough coalition to to achieve that and
the Labour Party has always been a
somewhat uneasy coalition between a sort
of metropolitan elite and industrial
working classes and I think it's really
very important to have both of those
pillars behind the party and what about
the way that the party has dealt with
the anti-semitism rao did they do enough
and have did they do enough soon enough
and have they done enough now no I don't
think they did do know soon enough I
think they're now getting to grips with
the problem but you know we simply
cannot have anti-semitism in the Labour
Party that's it so has that as well as
Jerry Collins you Europe stance as well
as local and Scottish election results
at any point given you any pause for
thought about the money that you choose
to donate to live well I've been
involved the Labour Party for 50 years
or something and it's had its ups and
downs and I haven't always agreed with
the policies that it's pursued
but I'm a kind of tribal Labour's party
supporter and I'll stick around and do
my level best to try and and gather
party to promote the sort of policies i
think that workable so you will continue
to pass the Labour Party under jeremy
corbyn yes